T
EP TASE
WHE
> LLLSO IN
IAL IG ITAT THNEW CRIMINALNST
ALLEGEDLY, INMATE WITHCED INS
CELL PMPTINGUVOLNY TO
T ED'SG MORE PRIN IT 12 YEARS  N
JOINING  IS DAUG NAVALNAYA.'S G.
FIRST, ITO SWHAT'S HNOT T
E  A L JUDGNGN ETHEE DEFEBECOMEI
HAOT
T,E , MYADRE T ANDSEUMES, AN
PR IF  DT  THERE'SDOUBLECED PAG.
REFORCEDMMUNICATUGH
THEY CAN EXC
CAN'T SE THAT ISAGAINST MY, WHI
GREAT PO
OU
SH NE THIS ES KE T AOF THEAY PU
MCE., BUT IT IS
I WONDER, THIS PLAOUT, A FORE, O
MENTIOE ISONING TEWH HOPE ASTHI.
AVF TH PROEM
SYSTEM BEING
SW GOVERNMEN
'TE
HEARING OIO HAPPEN
WEWHETHER IT'S GOINGOS
AND, YD THIS NTH
ABLEM FOR TICAL PRISONER IN  GG
ST GOING
TOE PUT INT USON
EI.ATT  THE TI
ST C YOU WHAT UROWLEDGE IS AT TT
ACE
ATHECOOUGH
ER SP,ARE YONCERNED THAT AUTHORT
S FE?
>> O.
THERE'S ALWAYS T
WORSINTHADM N
Y NGDA T
DREW UP ADS NO AMOUN CAN PNTH DO
HUMAN BE OUTRAS USSTROYED.E CAEA
I'M  A T
ADTENG TO
S STRIPPINEVTILEEAPORTANT -- H
A POLIIA RIGHTF SU
IT'S DELI NEEDTHIS BOULD NOT DEI
YOYO ARE FORCED T C
IT  HOW'S YR DOING?
HOW ARYOU G? I'M ALL RIGHTELL
YOU CAN DO IN A SITUA
LIHIS AT SYING.
STDERGRADUATE STUDENT AND HANGPD
SIT HERE AND STUDY AND DO THE
MOST I CAN T
THAT'S TKSEINGERE --CATION I'T
AZPPM A K UPO INS HER.
ROLE >> WELL, I'M SURURR